the Honeydew with ran
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler
docomo media and I'm starting this show
like I start them all by saying thank
you thank you for supporting this show
thank you for supporting the pat Ron the
crab feast and thank you for supporting
the new pod the way back you guys loved
it got off to a great start I'm very
excited for it um look you got to help
out the Pod all the freeways subscribe
rate review all that stuff do it on
Apple do it on Spotify do it wherever
you can okay um and there's a separate
audio feed for this if you're a person
that just likes to listen hey go
subscribe to that audio feed all of this
stuff is is free for you and it helps
the Pod now if you missed last week's
episode with Tom seore there's going to
be a five minute preview at the end of
this episode so watch all the way
through the end there'll be a fivem
minute preview of the Tom sagora episode
and then the episode coming up this week
we get we take Mark Norman on the way
back all right so that's the deal with
the new pods called the way back every
Thursday right here on my YouTube
channel you're getting the Honeydew
you're getting the Honeydew with y'all
you're getting the way back and you're
getting the feast all right right and if
you don't know about the Honeydew with
y'all you got to subscribe all right
you're getting the Honeydew a day early
ad free and the way back a day early ad
free at no additional cost all right so
head over there it's the best stories
you're going to hear on Hell anywhere TV
online all of it it's your stories and
it's absolutely awesome uh please keep
supporting my special Lefty Sun we're
not even a year in on that thing yet and
we're coming up on a million and that's
my goal all right and if you haven't
seen me on the road and you're in town
when I'm around come see me all tickets
for my tour are available ransler
docomo over here we're highlighting the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers I am
very excited to have this guest on
ladies and gentlemen first time here on
the Honeydew please welcome Patrick Rena
welcome to the Honeydew thank you thank
you I was stoked to get you on here bro
I I I was stoked to do it thanks for
having me it's very kind of you to do
this um I love that highlight the low
lights it's brilliant right it's a it's
an elevator pitch you get it right when
you say it like you're like I get this
it's get you [__] know what you're
talking about I started crying
immediately when I was in uh College uh
in the mid 1990s the late 1900s I uh
will never forget studying film and one
of the things was about pitching and
just can get the get to the do it in an
elevator you got 30 [__] seconds get
it done and I remember the pitch for
alien the very first 1970s alien they
said it's jaws and space and it was done
done and I was like oh my God yeah Jaws
in space what of course I'm in yeah
we're in so yeah highlighting the low
lights is exactly what it is I'm tired
of everybody's ESPN top 10 highlight
Instagram [__] here's how great my
life is let's really see what's going on
so before we do please plug promote
everything and anything you would like
yeah I mean we were just talking about
it you know I all my socials are Patrick
Rena um so you can check that out I'm
diving into socials a lot more starting
a YouTube channel um I have a apparel
line now hamino Athletics so that's
hamino athletics.com and then uh I'm
going to start a podcast myself soon uh
probably I guess you could say a
fatherhood I need to work on my elevator
pitch I don't even know it yet so but
it's a fatherhood uh Centric podcast and
uh just you know
or you know any Parenthood type thing so
we'll have guests on and talk about it
and then even if they don't have kids
we'll talk about how they don't have
kids in that sort of angle of life and
just uh H have a good time doing it so
great I'm gon to snap some pictures of
your studio because it's [__] great
thank and I want take you don't mind
okay good I don't mind at all okay good
um well first of all I want to I want to
get to know you because I think like
most of us all you're first of all
you're an icon you're a childhood Legend
yeah uh in one of the most famous movies
of all time it's quoted everywhere I'm
sure there are gazillion [__] memes
out there as well right yeah um but I
want to talk to you because I don't know
you and I would love to know first of
all where you're from originally um and
what your what childhood was like for
you before all that cuz how just real
quick were you 13 in that movie yeah I
was uh yeah I was 13 when I filmed it 14
when it came out so so let's talk about
life before that then start there pleas
yeah I think I mean I'm from Boston um I
was born and raised there I I left when
I was
12 um and I think that's you left with
Mom Dad by myself I said no just kidding
I was going to be like you're not one of
those kids they just shipped your ass
yeah get the hell out of here um no I uh
I left with my mom my mom and dad split
when I was 11 and I was in I went to
boarding school for a few years and I
always you know uh I always appr what's
that like well at a young age it was
wild and is that a sleepover thing for
you it is okay you're going away and you
do your own laundry and you know and how
old are you I was I had my 11th and 12th
birthday doing it so why well I so I
think that my parents sent me away
because they were getting a divorce and
I you know that my memory of it is not
this like horrible messy divorce so I
kind of always appreciated that it just
you no SI me yeah and I remember my mom
telling me cuz at the boarding school
was in Oregon on like a Mountaintop
overlooking this like beautiful Valley
uh she told me they were getting
divorced and it wrecked me I was like
you know that's where she told you yeah
but she I think she wanted me to have
space and sure and I had a rough time
with it but I always appreciated that
they sent me away for that because
they're really good friends now they'll
stay at each other's homes they're uh
they're both remarried their husband and
wife wife or they you know they'll go to
dinner the four of them and that always
meant a lot to me because I have friends
whose parents want to rip each other's
jugular jugglers out still to this day
40 years later right and you're like wow
you still you got you share kids how can
you carrying that poison and that toxic
[__]
Behavior I think that kills you in the
long and it meant a lot to me that they
that they I didn't experience any of
that negative what did your parents do
for a living uh that you know what they
they were business partners
in I don't even know what it was it was
some sort of uh it was before computers
so whatever you know some sort of
technology company before computers so
typewriters I don't
know they they did something you know it
was that kind of world and they owned it
with this other guy um and so that's
what they did and so then they're
splitting you go to this boarding school
where Oregon okay that's where it was in
Oregon so I was kind of back and forth
between Oregon and Boston uh and at that
boarding school you're learning
basically to take care of yourself is
that what they're teach which is wild
like so I say I want when you said the
age I'm like all right my daughter's
nine I want to hear what they got you
doing at 11 laundry you're doing laundry
you're doing laundry they they have they
have um I don't know what they call it
now like a personal teacher is what they
called it which was essentially like a
not a guardian but just one of the
teachers is assigned to every kid is
assigned to a teacher outside of class
so they like sort of just make sure
you're doing okay A bit of a chaperon so
I used to steal laundry tokens from her
it was great uh but she was I know uh
she she was awesome and to help me also
my parents would come out and visit a
lot I would go home I wasn't there in
the summer so it wasn't so they're
figuring their [__] out to split
amicably and there's a business involved
as well you're over here also learning
responsibility and how to take care of
yourself yeah and I I you know they
never really confirmed that that's why
they sent me but um I think it is like
you know but then you come back well so
the only negative is it was all you
could eat buffet are you being serious
I'm being dead serious my friend from
Zer to 11 I was a skinny kid I'm not
kidding now my dad it's true my dad when
he was a kid was a fatty just like me so
I obviously have it in me to you know
get big but I put on some pounds you ate
those feelings H ate those ate the [__]
out of those and I remember my mom
seeing me picking me up and like oh
you're done there you're
done so she pulled me to La she knew I
wanted to be is that right it was true
it's true she knew wanted to be an actor
too so it was probably a you know double
thing but if you I so I moved to LA and
you know with Mom with Mom and she had a
job opportunity out here um at like an
investment firm or something so mom's
going Boston to Oregon to scoop you up
and then get the [__] out of there and
we're now we're in La at what like 134
you about to start high school yeah so
91 I landed in La 12 12 okay now where's
Dad he stays in in Boston right uh but
still good relationship okay great
relationship they both you know meet
significant others a year or two after
they divorce so like they're they're
kind of it's funny their
paths outside of divorce are very
similar and it's funny you know they
like they they both got married around
the same time to you know younger they
both went younger good for them you know
what I mean yeah they both were about 10
years younger and uh they've been with
them ever since so okay um
yeah so it was I I'm in La I'm uh you
know she I I start dieting for one and
then uh you know start acting um you
knew you wanted to be an actor that
young huh I did you knew it I did school
plays um in Boston and I did some
modeling uh and yeah what what turned
you on to that your parents were in like
the professional world so where are you
getting I don't know I I I try and think
about that I think I just had that
personality and I I never really was
forced to do it you know I didn't my mom
didn't go on sets with me we would hire
people she refused to be a stage mom uh
which is really funny because I saw this
documentary later for free Willie so
this is I did a my first audition was
Sandlot and I I booked it but right
before that isn't that crazy that's a
Mega Millions lottery yeah it's a my
first first audition was Salute Your
Shorts which was this TV show back in
the day I booked it my second audition
was sand I booked it so I'm like two for
two which I feel like this I'm setting
up what this podcast is about cuz I had
this great beginning you know yeah then
I meet Paulie Shore and I yeah yeah do
you still get residual checks I'm not
asking how much but still something
comes in the mail does it not yeah yeah
we do for sand lot but it's not as much
you think like I don't even know what I
think it would be anymore I how old is
it now 30 years 30 right God but it's
still I mean it kir it was it was it was
top
25 the other day on iTunes that's what
I'm saying and I I was a little I and I
was with some of the other guys I was
like Jesus how's this movie still once
in a while popping up because it's one
of those generational [__] things it
just goes like a Wizard of Oz it really
is it was it was sorry good PA shore oh
yeah I'm just saying so I I finished
Sandlot I think my next audition I think
was for paully Shore and I booked it I I
I know I was two for two maybe I had a
few in there what was the paully Shore
movie son-in-law oh you were in
son-in-law a little kid in that um so I
I had a lot of success be in the
beginning but I was saying the the funny
thing was cuz I was saying my mom wasn't
a a stage mom so I I did do this cattle
call for free Willie right when I got to
La it wasn't an audition ition but they
just had thousands of kids in lines and
you would just walk up to this table and
they would say they'd ask you like five
questions and if you answered right
you'd go on to the next stage it was
really weird and honestly a little sick
but like it just do you remember any of
the questions well yeah so one of the
things is what sports do you like and I
forget what I said I think I said
basketball and I had such an attitude I
remember having an attitude which I'm
like why but then they said do you like
swimming and I said no I like math and
and then they sent me away I that was
done uh but later years later I see this
documentary and they're T it's about
stage moms and they have this found
footage of free willly cat cattle call
no and my mother is standing there in
the line you're in it my mom is in this
stage mom thing with her arms crossed
looking pissed but this is my Bostonian
mom who's like I don't have time for
this [__] like get me me out of here and
it's just funny that she's in that cuz
she couldn't be farther from a stage mom
because she just didn't want to do it
you know and that world when did you see
that did you tell her like hey Mom
you're not going believe she was so
P like she didn't like it her name's
also Karen so this whole Karen thing
she's all pissed out like she's just
already yeah she is she's from Boston
and just you know through just full
Boston
uh anyway so that I I think my my
parents did it right I think um as far
as I can tell you know I like to think I
have a good head on my shoulders but
just all those all those traps all those
um you know for for young Hollywood for
actors in Hollywood that people get into
they sort of help me avoid yeah that's
what you hear all the time the young
kids are getting introduced to drugs
early or you hear about the molestation
all the that's going on these adults are
even ignoring uh these kids you know so
you would have basically like a chaperon
that was hired to make sure that you
were like do what about schoolwork like
how's that happening so sand line we
didn't have any school it was summer
summer and my stepdad actually came with
me on S Lon okay uh he was he's a
photographer too so he has these really
cool old photos that oh hell yeah they
let them shoot behind the scenes yeah
like you could never do that now but
this was 1992 and sure come on in and he
was like a set photographer for free and
we have all this great stuff oh hell
yeah um so school school was was fine
there uh as I got older and did other
movies during you know the actual School
season I I would do uh I would do school
on set
which you know school on set at least in
the 90s was a joke I mean I remember I
played chess with my set teacher on
son-in-law like you know and he he was a
great guy don't get me wrong like we had
fun but like they're trying to learn a
curriculum that you're getting somewhere
else and figure out how to do this for
it's impossible you know you can't keep
up you so that that's a little bit of a
a difficult thing I think for young
actors is as schooling and keeping up
and I imagine too that like Sandlot for
instance is a bunch of guys your age
that's probably a fun [__] time but
but then you have son-in-law yeah and
they're mostly adults in that film so
are you starting to miss your friends
are you starting to feel isolated like
hey I'm not getting to hang around kids
my age um because you're working so much
and what kind of schedule are you
working you know are you there for a
week at a time or you know I
think luckily I came onto the scene I
think after
probably a lot of tragedy in Hollywood
because like cougan the cougan account
is uh based on cougan I don't even know
his first name but a kid back in the day
that had all his money stolen from his
parents yeah [__] like that you hear
about all the time right so I came in
right after stuff like that so they
luckily so there was some things in
place to protect you and things okay you
only work eight hours a day and you know
I I don't know I guess I just when I
moved to Hollywood I met with Judy
Savage who is is
the child agent of the 90s she was the
biggest thing uh wonderful woman she's
obviously since past she she was older
then but she said to me she set
expectations when she met with kitu and
don't don't uh don't expect to work for
two years and so I I went okay and then
I immediately was on 20th Century Fox
and then Disney and like working with
all these stars and so I guess I just
sort of ort of counted my blessings and
went wow like
I felt like I struck gold uh cuz I
didn't have these bad experiences um I
son-in-law was great for me I mean
Tiffany amth was on it and I think I was
in love with her my whole childhood so
and like you know she's such a she was
so fun Paulie Shore big brother to me
Carla Gino uh like a big sister to me
she was on it uh the who the
um Cindy picket was my mom and she was
incredible uh Lance Smith was the dad
these are just like these guys have been
doing this forever so and I was the only
kid so they loved me and they kind of
like took me under their wings so um I
had a good experience on that I I think
after son-in-law I did the Big Green
which was another Disney movie and it
was kids over the summer again we had a
great time time but that's where I
started you know I was 15 now MH um you
start getting interested in girls you
know uh it you're it's not just dudes on
a baseball field anymore and there were
some female stars in that movie that
were beautiful and you're like so you're
starting to hit puberty like this it's
kind of a weird time you know so that's
I think that uh that experience was fine
I was still young enough but
then after that that was my third big
movie I started experiencing I think the
down side of Hollywood the you know you
start you're 18 now 19
um I you know I got in really good shape
that during those years because I wanted
to meet people and you know um have a
girlfriend and things like that I met
some really close friends of mine that
we spent a lot of time together we were
the like the three-headed monster but we
definitely partied a lot you know and um
that's kind of I think when that when
you start to go uh what am I doing you
know the the two-day hangovers after you
know crazy weekends and things like that
I luckily I didn't get into drugs too
much um nothing pretty intense never
experienced that but you know just that
like young party scene now I'm
auditioning and now I'm getting rejected
and like
having experiencing what Judy Savage
warned me about but I didn't really
experience it till my you sort of got it
in reverse I got it in reverse which was
is interesting because I just had this
this um crazy launch and like just took
off like a rocket and then yeah and my
teens and stuff it slowed a little bit
um so I guess those those are the times
where you get humbled a little bit and I
always look at people that have an
attitude now and I go no matter who you
are you will be humbled it's coming and
it it doesn't matter and every single
person will be humbled and you just got
to remember that um because you just
want to treat people right you know as
much as you can I mean yeah everyone has
a bad day I do too but
you're just becoming a young man at 18
and now movies are not going the way
they were right did you ever have a
backup plan was there anything else you
ever wanted to be what was what were you
going through at that time are you
living by yourself are you still with
your mom no I moved out at
21 okay um and luckily never had to move
back in I didn't have a backup plan uh
did you go to college did you no no and
I I
mean I my stepdad's a contractor so I I
had there was a period in my
photographer yeah [__] all over
the place he he's not a professional
photographer he just really really good
he's one of those dudes that's like I'm
selftaught and you're like it's one of
the greatest photos I've ever seen in my
[__] life yeah I mean he has photos
from The Sandlot that are better than
the setar I believe it um but he you
know I
uh wait what were we talking
about um navigating life after things
are slowing down now and you have no
backup plan youge so I no I didn't go to
I didn't go to college and I oh I was
saying I had a little bit of real estate
background just because I would help my
stepdad oh he's a contractor yeah so I
so I never like flipped houses but there
was a period in
my late 30s when I had kids um where I
started doing some stuff in that world
that's kind of the only other thing I've
done but in my 20s I mean things are
cheaper then too I I had this house this
four-bedroom house with two roommates
and we each paid 600 bucks a month and
it was in Eagle Rock which I don't know
if like I know eag Ro I know back then
too now these are million yeah like
forget about it I had this mansion and
we used to have parties we was the the
famous orange house in high in Eagle
Rock so I didn't have a backup plan but
that's what's scary you know a friend of
mine was a professional pitcher in Major
League Baseball and he didn't you
allowed to say well you don't have to
well it's sure I won't because it's not
I mean he didn't it's funny when you you
look at professional sports players and
you realize how high Kobe Bryant was how
high LeBron James is how high Mike Trout
is because there's this whole world
below them of not even uh all stars but
people that make a good living and then
below them you're talking about Rel
relieving pitchers and then below them
you're talking about minor leag and
minor leagues and like the single a is
10 times better than you and I at
baseball you know what I mean like it's
crazy um so he didn't have a backup plan
and he was a starting pitcher in in
Major League Baseball and you know
because he didn't have a backup plan I
think after that was tough for him you
know uh so it's it's it's um it's an
interesting
question and I didn't really think about
it I graduated high school but I I
didn't have any other anything else I
was lucky enough to even my
downtime book things you know it's funny
too because a lot of people you know I
remember I was picking with sag the
other day and some guy drove by honking
[__] you guys get a real job and you're
like okay well that's one way to look at
it and yes Brad Pit has it really nice
and yes I have even myself I'm I've had
a Charmed career uh and I I I can't
complain about it you know but when I
grew up and you're not working a lot and
you book a guest star that guest star
paid you whatever it paid you $7,000
$10,000 to do it and then you it plays
on national TV you get another $10,000
then it plays again you get another
$10,000 so you do a guest star and a
commercial in in a year in Hollywood and
you make 50 Grand 40
Grand and you can live you know um and
you can live as an actor and what it
takes to get that is a lot but that
that's what everyone's fighting for now
too this we're not fighting for Brad Pit
like he's fine you know we're not even
fighting necessarily for a guy like me
we're fighting for these guys that are
coming out wanting to be actors and
they're waiting tables and they're
trying to figure out and they book one
guest star and it supports them thank
God because otherwise they're back home
to Idaho and you never get This
brilliant artist you know yeah so but
also sag let's give everyone Insurance
yeah let's give everyone health
insurance
let's not make it it is the percentage
of the Brad pits in the world to get the
health insurance I mean I'm in a union I
pay my union dues everyone we should all
get health they took health insurance
away during Co too which was pretty
rough that's pretty rough that was rough
for me I lost it then yeah yeah I lost
my smell I still I still don't have it
back yet yeah still off yeah yeah it's
true there there's definitely I mean is
there two sides to everything you know
and then what really sucks is
the crew that are working because those
crew that's what you think you don't
even think about how many the grips the
Gaffers AIO wardrobe hair they have all
lost their homes they lost and you're
like cool guys like you know we can't
really make a deal here huh right it's
wild the Honeydew is sponsored by better
help around New Years we get obsessed
with how to change ourselves instead of
just expanding on what we're already
doing right maybe you find finally
organize one part of your space and you
want to tackle another or maybe you're
taking your supplements every morning
and now you want to actually eat
breakfast too therapy helps you find
your strength so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick all right you know how
much we believe in therapy here we talk
about mental health all the time it's
not just about repping those muscles
it's about repping that mind all right
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
and flexible and suited to your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get match with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge celebrate the progress
you've already made visit betterhelp.com
honeydo toay to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com honeydew food can truly be the
best medicine which is why the farmer's
dog makes and delivers fresh healthy dog
food it's the developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and it's made
from real healthy ingredients to human
food safety standards traditional dry
food and wet dog food options are highly
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and are extremely difficult to portion
accurately the farmers's dog isn't just
fresh higher quality food they also send
the food pre-portion specifically for
your dog based on their unique
nutritional needs this makes it easy to
help your dog maintain their ideal
weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life a
fresh diet has also been found to have
all sorts of benefits from healthier
coat and skin a better breath and even
easier digestion things I've noticed
with Princess Lily Rose since we made
the switch get 50% off your first box of
fresh healthy food at thefarmersdog.com
Honeydew plus you get free shipping just
go to Farmers do.com honeydo to get 50%
off that's the farmers dog.com honeydo
don't reinvent yourself for the new year
just rehydrate yourself with liquid IV
with three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink plus eight vitamins
and nutrients for everyday Wellness
liquid IV hydrates two times faster than
water alone all in a single sugar-free
stick so you can feel like a hydrated
new youu ready to take on 2024 H listen
they say oh give me a personal
endorsement I'll give you one how many
years has liquid IV been with us that's
how much we love them that's how much
you guys obviously love them they're
legit everywhere I go that's the one
everyone talks about you got liquid IV
you got liquid IV you got any yep we
keep it here at the studio we give it to
the guest we take it on tour we drink it
here for daily use before a workout when
you feel run down after a long night out
and on Long flights one stick of liquid
Ivy plus 16 ounces of water hydrates
better than water alone and with non GMO
free from gluten dairy and soil you can
feel good about what you're putting in
your body rehydrate yourself for the new
year grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar free and bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 20% off your
first order when you go to liquid i.com
and use code honeydew at checkout that
is 20% off your first order when you
shop better hydration today using promo
code honeydew at liquid
i.com now let's get back to the DU so
let's go back to you uh navigating your
20 so so now that you're out of high
school you're not going to college
things are slowing down what what are
you doing uh for work you're still
booking things in your downtime but are
you are you panicking are you having
anxiety are you getting you know do you
get depressed that hey things were this
way now they're this way and if so what
are you doing to navigate all that yeah
I mean I guess
um I
definitely had anxiety about it I was
always smart so I was a saver um I never
really spent my money on anything no no
so I when I would work I'd put it away
and then when I wouldn't work I would
spend it to live um
so but yeah there there's definitely
were times where my bank account got
pretty low and you're like how am I
going to pay rent how am I going to do
this
um but luckily I I don't know I guess I
just figured it out I I booked enough
work where I booked enough work where I
could live I wasn't I didn't live on my
yacht but I you know was fine well you
seem like you really have your head on
your shoulders and you're not a yacht
guy aren't we all a little bit of a yach
guy though listen man here's the thing
about if you invite me to your yacht I'm
coming that's the thing yach you don't
ever I'm a yacht guest you know what I'm
saying you don't ever want to be the
dude that owns the yacht you want to be
the guy that goes and hangs out yacht
[__] I'm a private jet guest I'm a yacht
guest gas yeah that's all I want to be
Vegas Gas whatever you want you got to
make that money to own yacht and if
you're making that money there are
sacrifices you're also making and mostly
those sacrifices end up being your
family and ultimately yourself [__] that
yacht yeah true let's go hang out on
somebody you know what I'm saying yeah
so um you've been able to throughout
your whole career right till now 44
years old you've been able to make your
living in just entertainment you've
never had to step outside you say you
dabbled in the real estate thing but you
never really had to shift gears like an
athlete does right whether that becomes
staying in the sport whether it's
announcing or whatever it is they those
people and you know who I really always
think about are the Olympians these are
these are people that give their whole
lives to this one activity sport
whatever it is I and I I don't mean this
I just mean like you might just be doing
the Rings right your whole life when
that shit's over even if you're the
greatest gold medalist ring person in
the world what are you doing now that's
what drives me insane what are you do
cuz you're young as [__] when you're out
of there you're even these athletes are
only in their 30s when they're you know
washed up unless Michael Phelps and you
have advertising and but that's why I
don't understand why they don't get paid
like someone's making tons of money off
the Olympics how and they're putting
tons of money into their training over
all these years you know with like I
even played on travel teams that shit's
not cheap none of it's cheap you know no
it's true I I it's uh it's a really good
point I mean athletes
have it rough I think that's why you
hear the sad stories a lot too after so
let me ask you this you're a child actor
uh who comes up and successfully is able
to navigate all that keep your head on
your shoulders yeah and now you have
kids yeah now the only thing I would say
is you know one of the reasons I think I
didn't get so [__] up is I really
wasn't a child actor okay because I was
13 you're and remember what you were
doing at 13 you're not a kid I'm not six
oreven you're not six you're not no
one's going to molest me do you know
what I mean like not I
mean no but you know we've heard plenty
of I guess that's true I shouldn't say
that but you know what I'm
like guy yeah girl guy that's 13 they
they can kick your shins pretty hard and
obviously there's terrible stories no
matter where but um cuz what no matter
what age there are people who are
vulnerable and they're yeah yeah and I
didn't mean that you know what I me
physically you weren going to lock me in
a a a room
and I would at least me either I'm the
guy's telling oh man every I'll kick in
the [__] nuts and then go tell
everybody what you did yeah and you know
what you're doing a little more at 13 so
I I feel like those those really messed
up stories like the one you told me in
the waiting room at 3 yeah that I
luckily avoided that you know um I was
we were talking too about like these
days because internet wasn't even around
when we're doing this stuff you're doing
this especially and you know now a kid
can go viral at 5 for opening [__] so
that's terrifying as a parent are you
cuz I told you out there I don't want my
daughter going anything in comedy
nothing yeah I mean not even managing
booking like it's just an insane asylum
inside this world here uh I will
encourage or support I should say and
anything she wants to do uh reasonably
but man I hope it's not this I know it's
tough I I will support anything they
want to do as well um you know driving
around Hollywood driving your kid around
in traffic for auditions though I don't
know we'll have to talk about that like
maybe they get a car and then they can
be an actor you know um but yeah I don't
it's it is scary being an actor in this
world is scary um being and
anyone that has you know in front of you
You're vulnerable you you don't want to
when we grew up I mean we're almost the
same age I'm a little younger than you
but similar Generations
um it was different there were no
cameras there were no you know you
didn't everywhere you turn now someone's
filming you everywhere um and we all say
the wrong thing once in a while you know
we all do stupid [__] catch me before
coffee I'm not a nice guy
like I'm sure you know like but after
and if I'm prepped for it I'd like to
think I'm I can be a good guy so that's
that's what bothers me the most about
this world is how unforgiving it is I
just that's that's something that's hard
to watch because we are human and by
Nature we make mistakes and that's not
an excuse for a mistake that is
unforgivable either but that that's
rough to watch in this day and age
people just have their life taken away
ripping each other down for nothing for
something they don't even really mean
like you know
mhm so do you talk to your kids about
have you watched the sand lot with your
kids um I yeah my old my six-year-old
watches it a little bit um and he likes
it I think he gets a little confused
like it's different because I'm in it so
like I watched The Goonies with him and
he loved it riveted that's the one yeah
watch I my daughter loves your movie too
but Goonies and Sandlot are the two she
loves yeah
he doesn't there's no confusion he just
loved it and that was I see why parents
uh get excited and come up to me and go
my kid loves it because when I showed
him Goonies I had the chills the whole
time I was like this this was my
favorite movie growing up it still holds
up oh for sure your movie and Goonies
and ET yeah those childhood movies still
hold up yeah they're still great to
watch even it's funny cuz I was a kid
seeing these things and now I'm with my
kids seeing them and watching her react
and I'm still getting feelings about it
and stuff like this [__] this one's
great oh you a see we do Friday Night
movie night we usually try to get pizza
or whatever and then we sit there and
watch some movies I let her stay up a
little later on the weekends whatever
especially if it's for Goonies or sand
line yeah hell yeah yeah and now your
dad so your mom's living in La doing all
that dad's in Boston so how often is he
visiting and is he also supporting this
and helping you out with it as well yeah
I mean he he supported me and went to
private schools and um he would come out
and visit he would come on sun sets he
would meet me there and then I would go
back home and visit him cuz a lot of
family back in Boston yeah like my
before you know like when my
grandmothers and grandfathers were alive
um I would go see them and had cousins
and uncles and all all the so everyone
was Boston except for you except for me
and my mom yeah okay yeah and then um do
you is he your dad still alive yeah okay
do you ever sit back and talk to him
about holy [__] you're in the sand lot
yeah I mean I think uh do you let
yourself enjoy it or are you just like
it's such a part of you now that it's
like I don't let myself enjoy it that's
an interesting question um I don't think
I do I think it's such a part of my life
that like I was just in Nashville with
two of the guys and we were in a car you
still talk to some of them well yeah
once in a while we'll do an appearance
or something
um so I'll see them when we do those but
I was in the car with them in Nashville
and uh I let myself enjoy it in that car
ride I looked at them and I was like
this is weird right guys and you're also
still alive right all of us are in
business that takes people all early
sometimes and rips them to shreds yeah
um and a lot of the guys are doing other
things now too but some are still in the
industry or you know around but yeah I
think that was a moment where I we were
like chuckling together and I was like
it's pretty crazy so once in a while it
settles in when you meet like three
generations of people that have all
watched it it kind of hits you and you
go wow
that's that means a lot to these people
and that that's pretty crazy that we did
one movie and it's been being watched
for 30 years two questions about that um
I want to know one of
the like most powerful stories you've
heard from somebody like coming up to
you where that one really stood out and
I also want to know when at 13 it hit
you like holy [__] this is really
something um God powerful stories I I
think when three generations come up to
you that's pretty powerful grandfather
dad and the son all coming up being like
we [__] love this movie and the son
loves it and you're like you're six and
they say you're my child and I go you're
still a child but you're my old child
that's pretty special like yeah you know
I I had one uh for some reason it stuck
with me so bad maybe because I'm a
father now and I even try and get
through it is going to be hard but I met
a couple in Salt Lake City we went back
where we filmed it and they rebuild the
sand lot every five years and their kid
had passed in a car wreck and they still
came and they had a tattoo of him and
that [__] yeah
bro anyway I didn't mean to do that it's
okay that's what we do here dude um
that's really nice they still came yeah
so I'll shift this off of that for a
second so you every five years what you
they rebuild what do you mean they
actually rebuild the field um yeah they
every five years they rebuild the sound
that they they've done it three times
now so for 15 years they did the 20th
the 25th and now the 30th you go yeah a
lot of us go I did I go all three times
yeah I went all three times the second
time I I got the the stomach flew uh and
that was pretty awful but you take your
kids with you when you go uh yeah no I
never took them I I brought one of them
to Utah and I brought him by the sand
lot but on a different time uh but uh
yeah so I've I've made it every year
except that second one I didn't I you
know I I went for a little bit but then
was throwing up the rest of the time
uh but they oh it's the it's the
backyard of like 10 houses
five houses and it's all shared and it's
actually it's it's in like a is it the
actual yard where the ball goes over
like those actual yards yeah so they
they have they basically when they
filmed the movie they just rented
um they rented their backyards and they
built a sand lot on five it's like a
little middle class neighborhood you
know nothing too special really cute um
and they they just built they I mean
it's not that hard to build a sand lot
what is a sand lot a shitty baseball
field you know they threw a little dirt
and it's there but then they built these
facades of the houses that are in there
and a big tree they like brought in some
big tree for the um the tree house and a
whole thing so uh that was the samlot
and they kind of remake it they put the
back stop up and then they'll do like a
uh a big uh
Jumbotron um blowup thing and watch the
movie and we come out and they do a Q&A
and we'll sign
yeah that's awesome yeah it's cool it's
cool um James Earl Jones right has he
ever come or did he ever come no I never
I didn't even meet him he so originally
that in the movie it was supposed to be
um trying to picture it in my head you
guys are never in the same scene n or
they just cut it that way we were
written into the scene with him but then
on the day the director made a lot of he
shifted gears on the day a lot um and he
just decided to just put the two leads
in the scene with him so we weren't in
the movie with him never even met him he
W like when he arrived on set too it was
like oh the movie stars here you know
like you just felt it this is James R
Jones even 13-year-old kids know oh
you're Darth Vader like yeah oh you just
did Field of Dreams oh you're you are a
true legend um so you kind of stayed
away you know like uh and he's a big guy
too yeah he looks like a big dude Vader
can't be a little [__] no he can't he
was not a little [__] and he had a
massive trailer we had these all of our
trailers they put us opposite sides how
many you one for James Earl and Jones
yeah exactly so we but they also kept us
away from him I think they were like we
a't gonna have these little shits like
you know say something stupid James so
and he was there a day maybe two um
that's kind of how it was with all the
adult actors in the movie they were
there very short periods of time they
kind of banged it all out and none of us
were in any of it with them it was just
Tom gyri really and then Mike varar was
in with James R Jones because Dennis ly
was in it that's right yeah but uh Tom
had the scenes with him and Karen all
his ball isn't it his ball is it was it
Dennis L's ball you all [__] up oh yes
yes yeah I thought you were saying in
real life yeah yeah yeah his ball
yeah
so you say you don't let yourself enjoy
it why do you think that
is I don't want to get put you let you
off the hook here but I use this example
all the time there's so many people live
their lives and and it's been part of
their life that it's just something they
when they mention and move on like I the
example I always uses Joey Diaz I don't
know if you know who Joey Diaz a
comedian but he goes uh after I got out
of prison for kidnapping that guy I went
to Colorado I'm like hold on yeah listen
I don't give a [__] about Colorado right
I want to hear about it after I got out
of prison for kidnapping that guy like
and he says it like it's just because it
is it's just this part of my life yeah
so uh why do you think uh you don't let
yourself enjoy like what this really is
for
you um I
think I'm trying to think why I don't
know that I have what hit you in the car
car what hit you in that car just
recently when you were sitting there
looking and being what what was it that
you allowed yourself to just take a
moment that's that still were being
asked 30 years later to travel around
and out of all the guys I still look
very similar you know so it's constant
with me like we'll be together in a
restaurant and I'll get recognized and
then they'll and then I'll say and once
in a while they'll go will you take a
photo and and it's I kind of love it
because I go I think you want them on
this side too and they're like why and
then I'm like because that's denunez
that's squence and then they freak out
which is kind of fun to me because then
they're like oh my god um but I think
yeah I I guess what hit me is that I
that we still have this effect on people
and that you know um it it means that
that much and we still get asked to come
around for one movie you know um I think
why I don't let myself enjoy it is cuz I
I'm not done and I don't want to be done
you know yeah I guess that's the truth
of it is I love it I it doesn't
embarrass me um I don't mind leaning
into it uh I don't like to lean into it
too much but you know um I think I'm not
done so being a dad let's talk about
being a dad now you got uh how old a six
and a three yeah six and three both boys
you said um biggest fears as a
father
um I mean obviously you don't you know
you want to take care of them and you
want them to live long and healthy lives
and um you don't want them to get into
trouble I think I think that's probably
the biggest fear is like raising them
well enough so that they don't do one
stupid thing once that changes their
life forever
um you know are your parents uh both
involved good grandparents yeah oh yeah
they love it yeah and so that's nice
because they get along and they can
actually be in the same room with your
kids and not being like [__] that one
[__] that one over there and their
significant others are actually almost
even more involved like I said at the
top they're younger so they're they got
my stepmom and stepdad are great with
them too and they love them um how were
your parents you said it was very uh
around the same time how old were they
when they got remarried like how old are
you when step parents come into your
life 13 13 right there on the spot so
two years after they divorced pretty
much but they've probably been already
over it a week
after you know what I mean I'm pretty
sure I didn't meet them when I could
have you know hey honey let me introduce
you to someone I just met yeah [__]
right yeah yeah but at least they both
did it so they they were on you know and
were you itive to that right away no no
no tell me about that I I did not uh so
you were okay with your parents being
separated and divorced I I mean I don't
mean okay I accepted it but you accepted
that yeah now these new people coming in
you're like n [__] that yeah on both
ends yeah I did not get along with
either of them at all in the beginning
why because I intentionally didn't I it
was you you're admitting it
100% I was an [__] to them yeah I
mean [__] I'm an [__] to my parents
like imagine two people I don't even
love yet you know who was the first to
bring someone in you get a stepdad or
Mom first well my stepdad because when I
moved to
LA he was in the picture a month later
you so so do you looking back or have
you even ever asked your mom was he
already in the picture was Los Angeles a
destination regardless of Los Angeles
was a destination regardless yeah um but
very quickly I don't need ask them I
know the truth you know like they that's
the thing when you get a divorce you you
were divorced two years ago you know
what I mean so like they were they were
faithful people and I know that they
didn't do anything that the other would
have had a problem with but yeah they
were already divorced so they both
pretty soon after were together with
someone but you know yeah I my stepdad
was more in my life than my stepmom at
the time because I lived in LA and then
we moved into Glen a house in Glendale
and you know they've been at that house
ever since and he's been in my life ever
since so so when he went on set to shoot
you weren't getting along or were you
just no that's interesting cuz we were I
mean no we had a hard time on there too
but you know like
he's we had a hard time but I would say
we had a hard time like a parent and kid
have a hard time too like I still
respected them it's not
like I ran away from them or
disrespected them to the level that they
could help raise me you know um but I
had had a year with him too like 12 was
when he was in the picture a year later
I booked a movie you know and that
probably helped our relationship you
know um with my stepdad think about what
ends up happening in hindsight this
motherfucker's coming to photograph one
of the most iconic movies ever I mean he
hit the jackpot but also I own the he
owns the rights to images of me then
that nobody else does that I can use for
him being know Athletics like you see
what I mean like I can't use 20th
Century Fox images or Getty Images or
any no and he owns them so you're like
thanks dog you know like oh yeah so I
think that helped us my late teens or
mid teens we had a hard time together
you know can I ask you did he have kids
no so do you think also cuz I I I didn't
nether one nether my step that's what I
wanted to so they're not parents they're
just a spouse to Mom and Dad and
tempting to be which is part of the
problem because my friend is dating a
girl who neither of them have kids and
you know when I said I want to do this F
this fatherhood podcast I want to have
him on because he's a pretty successful
actor and I don't think he wants kids
but I think that's fascinating too you
know like and it's okay you know you're
like tell me why and if you don't want
kids don't have kids like that is the
one piece of advice I will give people
you're about to get into a whole world
of [__] and it's the most beautiful
thing you've ever been involved in if
you want it but boy it takes over your
life yeah if you don't you're going to
[__] hate it and though his
girlfriend now although I don't know if
I can call he would kill me for calling
her I don't think they're there yet but
they will be so we'll call her his
girlfriend uh she just like her ex had
kids and she was like I don't think I
want kids after that experience so and
probably the kids were probably great
but my stepparents they were not parents
they
didn't and what I did wasn't cute or
endearing like my like it would be to my
parents like right you're just an
[__] you know did they try to parent
though yeah you yeah and I probably push
back on that my stepdad more my stepmom
wasn't in my life as much she has come
into my life more now that I have had
kids she is fantastic with my kids and
they love her um and my dad's older he's
74 so so he doesn't get you know he's
doing good he's very healthy guy but he
doesn't get around as much so she's like
bending down there and building [__]
with them and you know they love
it uh and so yeah but I I think that's a
good good thing you spotted on that is
yeah they weren't parents and I think
that made it more difficult for I I
agree yeah there's a you're right it's
not it's also not your kid it's not like
oh it's great he's coloring awesome yeah
matter what I'm not their kid right even
though you know it's Father's Day and
things like that are always a little
interesting Mother's Day you know I I
have a dad I have a mom but these guys
have been in my life it's they should
almost have like step parents day you
know where you celebrate they've been in
your life for what 30 years 30 years God
damn that's a long time also good for
your parents too for realizing hey we
came together we had this Union we had
this beautiful child that's what this
relationship's about let's shut it down
and move on and be happy and they both
did yeah it's not like they each one of
them rotated Partners like they found
that person locked it in and they've
been together yeah that's [__] great
yeah it's cool yeah and it doesn't hit
you till a little later that all right
we can like when do you back off when do
you finally yeah I don't know that I
still have I'm not going to lie I mean I
don't know that I still have like I'm a
dick to them I you know I'm a weent and
kid relationships are so weird you get
so annoyed by them and then you
immediately feel bad and then you call
them and go I love you you're the best
thing I'm please don't hate like I'm
sorry I was a jerk like it's that's our
relationship I don't know what to say
I'm I'm closer to them than anyone in
this world so and that goes for my step
parents too like my
stepdad after my parents is another
parent my stepmom now now that she's
also helped so much with my my kids and
her grandkids similar I have such a an
appreciation for her now is it wild to
you that these same people you res are
resented or pushed back on now are
loving on your kids oh in the way wild
the way the Life Works it's wild and
it's also wild to now experience my kids
with me because it makes it makes you
realize like you punk you don't know
what I'm doing for you constantly and
then you go oh wait but I already forgot
that my parents did that for me
it's weird right like you don't you
don't realize how how much a parent
gives up for you and I mean it's
literally everything for three years
you're the other day I'm I wiped both of
my kids asses in the span of 10 minutes
like not even 10 two minutes I'm like
wiping [__] and washing my like between
dogs kids like the amount of [__] I've
handled over my life it's a lot of [__]
and you're dressing feeding him you know
getting them ready for this yeah we're
getting ready to go to laoya and I got
to get the dog ready my daughter ready
me ready yeah a lot that those early
years too and you're you're out of it
but now you're into a whole another
world ny- old woman good luck woman
that's what I feel like I live with you
do are you kidding me yeah I mean that's
what I hear Boys young are wild and
girls older are more uh you got to use
your mind a little bit more yeah I'm
trying trying to be like um more open
with her and different cuz I don't want
just that boy mindset the whole time you
know sometimes I think it's good
sometimes like just get up and walk it
off you're fine yeah Dad I you're fine
yeah that shit's fine uh but like my
daughter doesn't know how to ride it but
she'll kill me for S she doesn't not to
ride a two wheel bike yet yeah she's
nine wow and I'm like you've been
[__] off basically you've had bikes
I've had them here with the training
wheels took you out you didn't want to
do it she does in her defense she likes
to scoot that's her thing she's rather
scoot great my kid scoot but I'm like
okay but you need to learn how to ride a
bike a bike is for transport it's more
than just Recreation you got to learn
how to ride a bike you got to learn how
to swim she's great swimmer that's good
that's yeah more important is swimming I
agree that's a life but you need fck a
bike is freedom especially when you can
go anywhere as a kid if I'm like you can
ride down the street and go to your
friend's house but I took her out last
night and I'm like just like soccer
practice we're going to go out and ride
this bike it's not going to be let's go
out and fart around that you need to
[__] ride the bike first night and
she's too big now to put training wheels
on a bike so I got her a nice bike for
her birthday and she just got to walk
and balance it she gets frustrated I
don't want to do this again so we're
doing it we went out last night I'm
holding the back of the seat I [__]
let go I don't tell her she's riding and
I go look and she looks over at me and
then she's like oh my God and she so she
got like four or five different times
she got like four or five really good
cranks great and then you know you see
that she scored her first goal man dude
I was so [__] though she scored her
first goal yeah her friend was there and
she goes I don't want my friend to come
cuz what if we lose like what if I play
in the goal and I let a goal in I'm like
what if you score your first goal and
then she [__] goes and scores her
first goal and dude I was stoked I'm
running up and down yelling and [__]
like it's the best yeah it is it's the
[__] best and I didn't have the best
upbringing but I did have the best dad
who did everything he could to be there
all the time and then that's the other
thing when you look back on things like
how the [__] did you work that job make
these practices make games I don't know
man yeah like you loved me you cared and
then he dies and then I'm like yeah you
literally you gave that's what I'm
saying if you don't want to be a parent
that could happen yeah you're willing to
give your life for this person or these
people and yeah good for you dude thank
you thank you for coming on here and
opening up and talking about all this
this is great I didn't get to I'm glad I
got to know you better I didn't know all
this yeah um all right now that
everything we've talked about and this
is interesting cuz for your age at 13
you you become a an actor um advice you
would give to 16-year-old Patrick
Rena ah god um be nice to Jonah Hill
when you meet
him I met you not I wasn't I met Jonah
Hill before he was famous and he came up
to me and said I [__] love you man I
I wasn't mean but I was just at a party
and we were I was like cool dude okay
and then sure enough couple years later
he's Jonah Hill uh [__] hilarious I
need to see him again cuz you know now
I'll be like I [__] love you man
uh God I don't know I I think I think I
just there I don't know I I there's a
few things I would say do differently
you know like maybe run on a few on a
few Concepts and I I think I did all
right but um
I guess I probably would say don't take
so long to [__] around you know uh
because it's nice for a little bit but I
think what I probably messed around from
like 18 to 22 23 probably 18 to 24 a
good six years was just wasting my life
you know and doing other things but uh I
think I could said maybe go 18 to 22
reel it in 18 to 21 you know yeah uh I
like that you're still saying enjoy it
just I pump the brakes absolutely
because if you don't enjoy it then then
you get that serial killer who explodes
at one moment and does something you
can't take back so you do have to get
out of your system a little bit too
everyone does I think awesome man well
thank you very much for doing this again
please plug promote everything you'd
like yeah uh well I the this uh
fatherhood podcast coming soon it'll be
on my socials at Patrick Rena and uh
yeah this new YouTube channel I'm doing
I got a couple movies coming out
probably next year um one's called you
got to believe uh Greg Ker's in it that
was fun Luke Wilson who I did uh X Files
with years ago was in it they're really
cool dudes um and then I did a boy a
movie called boys the summer with um
Mason T TS and Mel Gibson's in it so
that that's cool and that both of those
should be coming out next year all right
man thank you very much yeah um as
always Ryan sickler on all social media
ryanr
[Music]
[Applause]
docomo to be here all day we going to be
here all day baby I like this kind of
party welcome to the first episode of
the way back I'm Ryan sichler ryan.com
Ryan sichler on all your social media uh
I'm here with my guest on the first
episode ladies and gentlemen Tom sagoro
welcome to the way back Tom Sor way way
back man way way back this is the back
seat in the station wagon facing out the
back no seat belts Dash on the front
cigarette smoke probably in the air no
seat belts at all you see the of a car
just come up to here and you're like you
wave did you ever sit in that seat did
you were you old enough to have that
yeah did you ever give the shoot the
finger real quick try to P what are you
kids doing back there Stu pulling away
do it right now as we pull away buses
school other school bu they would flick
you off they saw kids they be like [__]
you I want to talk to you about just
like this is all about the stalgia
growing up and stuff and your boys who
I've hung out with and my daughter did
too we went fishing together
my daughter caught her first fish with
your kids we caught 18 fish and a turtle
yeah out there using hot dog which I had
never fished with in my life son I took
hot dog up here to Kenneth hon you know
what we caught what two turtles two
turtles turtles must love hot dogs I was
all fired up like I got I got a good one
I re a turtl but your kids are wild I've
seen stuff on your guys social media of
like keys in the toilet uh crayon all
over the wall like I have a daughter I
remember even before kids yeah I would
sit in a restaurant and be like look at
these [__] boys are climbing over the
[__] and girls are just sitting there
coloring and they're just you know
genetically better than we are monkeys
monkeys what's the wildest stuff you
guys used to do growing up what did you
used to do I mean I think you know we
used to take we used to every thing was
riding bikes you know so like as soon as
like you got home ride bikes we lived in
this neighborhood in the suburbs of
Cincinnati and we would just ride our
bikes and the craziest thing that I
remember doing at that age I'm talking
like seven eight nine that's when I
lived there you know I lived there from
I was born and I left when I was nine
but in that age range one time I went to
these you know there was always like a
field always like back through some
woods and one of the kids had an M80 and
uh he just was like oh this is supposed
to be like pretty big firework I didn't
really have a concept of what it was
what a quarter stick of dynamite yeah
and when that that thing blew off I just
just from the impact I already I was
like oh we're in trouble like I I
couldn't believe that we didn't get in
trouble I mean it left a [__] crater
you know we used to put those in
people's mailboxes and blow them apart
oh yeah it would blow the sides open and
the back off of it one time I got a fire
going uh on this like on this stretch of
Lake Michigan when we were in
Wisconsin and I just got cans of spray
paint and threw them into the fire just
say like a are you serious it was like
bombs going and Mists go flying
different colors in yeah yeah but that's
just like you don't think like we used
to do Roman Candle fights shoot them at
each other we used to do we used to take
gii Joe's or Star Wars figures and we
would like um tape like 12 bottle
rockets to them and then light them off
and see how see how far up it could go
and then once it blew up the pieces
would all come down we would shoot
fireworks off in the house like we were
terrible kids now my kids also like they
when they when I found Ellis painting
the walls with his hands I [__] lost
my mind did you ever do anything like I
didn't do anything like that as I one
time put I thought I was helping I put
water in my dad's lawn mower where you
put all the gas oh [__] it all up and
he was he was real nice about it he was
like did you put something in here I was
like mm he was like if I promise you're
not in trouble will you tell me and I go
I put water in there for you for you for
you filled it up
he was like okay uh but I was like
flipping out at Ellis the [__] pain
all over the what are you doing just
going crazy he what do they do he goes I
don't like when you yell at me when you
raise your voice I'm just a kid he says
that yeah he goes if you just talk to me
in a normal voice I'm like dude and I
just start laughing cuz he's being like
he's right and he's being like rational
I'm like why are you painting the walls
he goes sometimes my brain man my brain
man just tells me to do stuff I was
like okay I love it dude yeah